billy eilish has no time for her haters
that she respond in the best way to
someone making uh naming her one of the
worst dressed at this year's oscars i
mean i disagree with this
so this is what's so great and in
typical billy fashion she isn't too
phased as she records the video
responding to this comment from her
toilet
take a look
i hate to do it but here's my worst
dress from the oscars
i've had enough of her
i was told not to talk during that video
but i couldn't help it that is so
funny i love her
i love her but i also disagree with that
okay so as you uh remember billy turned
heads in this all-black look wearing a
ruffled gucci gown
what did you think about i mean look at
her hair i think she was
the mood i think she was incredible she
won an oscar she knew it was going to be
her now she had a good idea that was
going to be her night she performed and
she looked absolutely i love it i think
it has a lot of texture to it i think it
has character to it if that who she is
you know and it fit like you said with
her hair and she's what 20 years old and
she's winning an oscar so
listen i mean listen when it comes to
fashion you can either make the best
dress or the worst dress and i like the
way she acknowledges being on a toilet
but i mean there's nothing wrong getting
on the worst dressed list right well i
guess but i think you know that reflects
the designer i think people feel like
you know they need to defend their look
but so she did in such a cheeky way
that's what i like she didn't to me she
didn't take it that seriously
look at she's gorgeous she's just she
looks that
makeup looks so natural and hair and you
know it actually reflects who she is
she's been very open about not wanting
to wear all the time form-fitting
clothing and i don't know i just thought
she rocked i made it the worst dress
list and i was excited did you from what
for what event it was for the golden
globes so i made some best list and then
i can't remember it was i think it was a
you know done up yeah
and he called me the worst dress but
then jayla was under me so i was like
this is perfect i mean you're in good
company
[Laughter]
now shortly after winning her first
oscar for best original song billy spoke
with reporters backstage and had the
best response when someone referred to
her as an emo
teenager
i've seen you sort of grow up since your
first album came out yeah and when you
first came out you were sort of like an
emo kind of sad looking teenager
and now you're like laughing and having
a good time and you look very happy and
it's so nice to see
do you feel that you've had a change in
your career as the last couple of years
have gone along i mean i went from um 14
to 20. uh-huh so that'll do it you know
do you feel a lot better now
sure i mean yeah i was i was a i was
also you know
a very young teenager very you know you
you know teenagers
um but i
i don't know it's just growth and like
aging i think um but yeah i'm super
happy i feel so
like i think that i'm i'm just coming
into my um
being aware of what is good and
around me you know i think that when i'm
that young like when you're that young
it's like hard to understand how big of
a deal things are around you and how
um important things are and you know you
meet a kid like i'll meet people that
are younger than me and be like
wow they have no idea how cool this is
and it's just like they're kids i just
was a kid and i don't i didn't know and
i'm so so thrilled that that growing up
has has uh
taught me to just be like
more aware of the greatness around me
i love it she could have fluffed that
question off she could have laughed and
kind of been like no and then she gave a
really honest answer about how she feels
like she has matured over the years i'm
sorry she's she's just the hair i love
the hair
this is so amazing um yeah so definitely
people have some comments
about it yazzy's saying this i'll say
this comment she's not a fashionista my
opinion bjork would have worn that
and bjork's know her very unique she
wore one one yeah do you remember the
swan that wasn't
yet
i don't know about that but yeah it's
really interesting now roxanna's saying
this replying doesn't bother me
it's being on the toilet that i find a
little disrespectful what did you think
about that i mean i think that was the
whole point of it was to be
disrespectful to the person who said she
was the worst dressed list right right
like that
and janna's saying i think that question
was gross i love her response it's
interesting because it could have gone
it could have gone the other way too it
could have been like offensive right
yeah so that's why i actually think her
it's funny because i asked the question
what's emu teenager like
what is email you're so cool
like what were we having our meeting in
the morning when we're discussing our
topics i'm like what is that that's so
great
but you know what it's also her style
she's an artist when she first started
off she felt this
just the way she who she was that that
mood and and that's what made her music
people can relate to her music that's it
because she was authentically herself
and being her age
that's why everyone could relate to her
i mean you do see a lot of young kids
actors musicians growing up in this
industry and they're acting like adults
and they're 14 and they are not they're
not she's acting her age and i just love
that she's always surrounded by her
brother her family
oh boy that is just such an important
thing to have around you especially in
hollywood i know and then that's how she
wrote her music right she wrote it from
the heart what a question but i know she
looked amazing it was an amazing night
again she's 20 years old and she won the
oscars look what they've done her and
her brother mike she's definitely happy